my name is Mario oh yeah at the top and
then it's fun cuz they recently added
200cc variant at the tail end of the Wii
U lifespan and then all of a sudden
everyone is like are so [ __ ] fast and
then I'll deal with go to his channel
for the people watching this probably
don't know
[Music]
a tanooki bill yeah sure I know you
probably have favorites out there we're
gonna do this one good so Oh last time
if you go check out our YouTube channel
we just played this we tied for a second
so if I don't win it was it was awesome
it kind of reminds me of like the videos
we do that you guys may or may not have
seen yet with the making challenges
markiplier makes stuff it's just it's
really nice when we're all actually like
cooperating or not not not like fighting
to the death over everything I didn't
realize this was a [ __ ] bike oh did
you know that the bikes handle
differently than the carts oh yeah they
don't go any faster I think so it's like
a moot point overall but they
[Music]
[Laughter]
well this is horrible I can't drive God
last thanks for making me look good
though yeah
I don't think we're gonna time for
second that's the weird thing it's got
like guide wheel
[Music]
[Laughter]
I've never either this was on the Game
Boy Advance kidding
I always forget that like people cherish
the Game Boy Advance version this one
just cos like it was ridiculously cool
but I never lay to myself I don't know
why
[ __ ]
I never had a game or dance you do know
how to get more color yes
yeah I have and I was like I mean I
guess from a technical
[Music]
[Laughter]
well actually it's hard because
everything
I also hate getting points it's stupid
and worthless
no no it's points to you if you go
faster if you have ten oh no you can
fall off [ __ ] [ __ ] dude I've been living
my life on it
it was the Bulls evo thought you
couldn't fall out why mean from the last
few maps it just seems like it's just
been you actually I thought you were
doing better than old then you get that
one eight you're gonna pull it out
[Music]
[Laughter]
what's a video on my my career
those DS
[Music]
I'm glad to understand are you doing so
bad don't either yours
drifting a nose yep dripping around
every corner didn't know
like Papa taught me yeah nobody believes
me when I say that my dad's name is Mark
or that my middle name is mark they're
all like that's not true you're just
pandering
[Laughter]
no one believes before I don't know it's
like there's no way that your middle
name could be mark why mark has a pretty
common name there's only one Zed even
sure thing on you I haven't seen it
[Music]
I think so long as I don't get like ass
last I think I've got like to bring up
the rare
[Music]
half of this entire what if what if I
mean you know in child labor usually is
I'm waiting like I probably already
happened someone's life
[Music]
[Laughter]
wait oh I didn't get the bike worked out
really well
[Music]
when your keyboard
[Laughter]
[Music]